hi there Steve Kaufman here again gonna
do another little chat you know I put up
that last little discussion and I
noticed that you know how it is on
YouTube if you look up the e some others
some web video chat you have just done
you'll see some related youtubes and so
I saw some that were quite interesting
one was something by a British professor
our language teacher who talked about
language learning in web 2.0 and you
might find that if you look up one of my
videos you might see his but my
impression of his presentation it was a
nine minute presentation it was much
saluted by all the teachers but I think
he misunderstood and he saw a web 2.0 as
as yet another tool by which the
teachers can sort of control the
activities of students and learners and
I think web 2.0 is about the learners
taking over and the differences between
learners and teachers are kind of
blurred everyone contributes everyone's
a consumer everyone's a producer people
make sound files people learn from what
they're interested in they don't have to
follow the teachers agenda they don't
have to do sort of make work projects
that the teacher assigns them ideally
they get out of the classroom which is a
relatively inefficient place to learn
languages so but you might find out and
have a look at it I was not that
impressed with with what was there the
other there was a series of of webcams
by a professor Alexander our gauges are
jealous I don't know how he pronounces
his name and oh no before I go into that
one there was a discussion of Michel
Thomas of his
very successful method he has sold lots
he taught movie stars and charged a
fortune for doing so I have listened to
Michelle Thomas trying to teach your
teaching German which is his native
language he also does them in Italian
and Spanish and French where apparently
he has their pretty bad accent because
his accent in English is a sort of a
very strong Central European accent but
he's been tremendously successful and
but I listened to this explanation of
his theory and and yeah I mean I'm not
it is obvious that different people
learn in different ways and many people
are very happy with Michel Thomas and
his method of teaching but there's many
things there that I just don't agree
with it he says for example that there
are no bad students there are only bad
teachers if you can't learn it's my
fault the teacher well I just don't
believe that I think the teacher is
irrelevant
I wouldn't say irrelevant but the
teacher in terms of teaching the
language is not necessary the teacher as
as a resource as a person who encourages
as a person who provides feedback who
inspires who stimulates all of those
things yes and I see that more as the
role of a tutor as someone looking over
someone else someone who has already
learned languages and is providing some
support and encouragement to someone
else all of that is great teaching the
language I just don't see it I think
you'll learn the language
from the language he works very hard at
getting people to say things very
quickly but he doesn't cover a lot of
vocabulary and to me the whole thing
about language learning and if you want
to be able to speak and then converse
and be comfortable in many situations
you need a lot of words he doesn't cover
a lot of words he tries to get you to
speak from the beginning okay something
we'll want to do that it's not what I
want to do I'm not interested in
constructing whole sentences early just
so that I can say you know what is the
colour of you
or white horse I want to learn words
some of the things that I do agree with
he says it's important to relax I think
there are many people who create these
mental blocks for themselves that they
are too nervous to relax to enjoy the
language he says get out of your own way
I agree sometimes people are their own
worst enemies are too hung up about
grammar they're hung up about how they
sound they're hung up about being able
to get out of their own culture and so
forth so I agree with all of that
another major part of his approach is
that no reading well I think reading is
a tremendous way to access the culture
and the language and learn words and so
forth
so Michelle Thomas obviously is very
popular and but so there was a YouTube
of a lady explaining his system now
there was another series of youtubes
where a person by the name of Professor
Alexander are gages are jealous reviews
a number of the more popular language
learning books teach yourself as Cemal
colloquial I don't know if he did
Pimsleur Hugo he goes literally through
all of them and he gives you a sort of a
9 minute explanation going back to the
earlier versions of the 1920s and the
1930s interesting if you're interested
in a history of different language
learning methods he deplores the fact
that the methods are becoming simpler
with a greater emphasis on phrases and I
bring them there you can't teach through
unconnected phrases you want interesting
dialogue he likes the idea that some of
the earlier versions of some of these
systems seem to follow the same format
in every language so that they would
teach pronouns in lesson 1 verbs in
lesson 2 and and numbers in less than 3
and so forth tell me that's have limited
benefit because every language is
different some languages
have articles some languages don't have
the same range of tenses as other
languages he suggested that by learning
language a if the second book follows
the same format that'll help Lee learn
language B I don't see that at all I
don't think it really matters in what
order you learn the grammar you learn
through interesting content some grammar
concepts and say Japanese or Chinese a
Russian are gonna stick early some later
with some people than with others I
didn't see that at all he is very fond
of these sort of artificial scenarios at
the bank at the post office at the train
station and I've always felt those to be
to the extent that those dialogues are
artificial they're not that useful I
mean you need obviously in the beginning
you need some artificial dialogue
because you can't deal with authentic
content it almost doesn't matter what
that artificial dialogue is it can be on
anything it doesn't have to be at the
train station you won't or the bank you
won't be able to operate at the bank
based on the scenario you learn so you
could be learning anything it could be
you know how are you what did you do
with your children today it could be
anything it really doesn't matter so
having sort of parallel scenarios that
he talks about I don't see the benefit
he talks about some of them having in a
30-page the loss tree at the end of the
book and therefore you've learned all
these words well no you haven't learned
the words because there's a glossary
that's not how you learn words you can't
learn words by reading a glossary the
fact that some of the dialogues have all
these words in them fine there's just so
much better ways now to deal with
learning words some of the things we
think we're doing at link that are good
I have never been able to learn words
from a glossary it's distracting to keep
on having to look back to a glossary
that's the advantage of reading on the
on the web but I'm going to on my blog
post I'm gonna post the the URL for his
his website and for his YouTube's one of
the other things he's very fond of is
what he calls shadowing where you walk
around you know reciting these phrases
and so for them I mean I'm sure it works
for people doesn't work for me but
everyone is is different so yeah I just
put these mention these things so that
you can have a look and see what you
what you think I think it's a lot of
this is it just points out again to me
how different people have different ways
of learning but I think it might be of
interest to some people to explore some
of the youtubes that seem to collect
around my youtubes for you know whatever
reason having to do with how our YouTube
organizes itself so if you go to the
blog post you'll see some of these URLs
thank you for listening